Rebecca Lowe NBC Sports premier league
host and the Premier League is coming
back on NBC Sports Wednesday June 17th
she also hosts the new breakfast with
Beck's digital series it's always great
to see and hear from Rebecca Lowe did we
acquire you are you a US citizen no I'm
still not but we are edging closer by
the month to the day when I'm free to
apply so just hold your horses all right
now can I help speed it up because I
know people I got David Feherty I know
that was a great acquisition by the
United States we got David Feherty all
right
I've heard that before how is Teddy your
son years old during lockdown which is
crazy because I was just talking to you
in the in the wardrobe room that sounds
weird I mean like yesterday with him in
my belly so he's good he's done he's
back at school is school open so that's
great for him because we had him out for
like eight weeks and obviously it's
tough when you're little because they
always all they care about is
playgrounds and they're full of yellow
tape
and he just already cared about when is
the yellow tape coming down when I go
back school see my friends with a little
mental health is just as important as
your anion mental health so he's doing
really well much better than I was
little I saw that you were hosting
breakfast with Beck's and I have to
admit I thought it was with David
Beckham and I I tuned in and I went
where's-where's backs and then I go oh
no it's Rebecca Lowe so I love seeing
you I'm not disappointed I just I it was
a little bit of an adjustment there just
very low okay all right
the fact that the Premier League is
coming back it's a foregone conclusion
that Liverpool is winning is the Premier
League coming back for Liverpool no it's
not just for Liverpool because actually
that's about the most
the only foregone conclusion that there
is in there six points away two
victories at the most away from winning
it for the first time in 30 years so no
because that's going to happen it's
coming back for a myriad of reasons
first and foremost to try and save not
just the Premier League clubs down
because you know because you know
footballs so well underneath the Premier
League there are four professional
leagues and then underneath then there
are about five semi-pro Meek's right and
it's a pyramid with without the top of
the world without the bottom of the
period there is no top of the pyramid so
everyone needs to help each other and
the tops follow the Premier League are
really struggling really struggling and
they need money from the Premier League
and it all filters down so the Premier
League has to come back to try and help
football stay alive in the UK and
football to us is like the NBA MLB and
NFL NHL an MLS all mix them together in
the u.s. that's how big it is so it's a
huge announcement and they'll have a
huge impact on the country as I know it
sounds very trivial to say oh it'll lift
the nation but it really will lift a
huge huge portion of the nation being
able to watch football on television
again and we will they be able to
because all 92 games for the first time
ever every single game it's gonna be
available to that
what about crowd noise I've mentioned a
couple times on this show that I've
actually listened to a little bit of the
Bundesliga on radio and the crowd noise
helped the product I wasn't offended
wearing all its fake noise but what do
you think's gonna happen
what does NBC going to do with the
Premier League and it's Leicester City
it's not leister City
it's Leicester City
anyway I dressed and we are in
conversation but I think all right I
actually have watched some of the games
from the Bundesliga and with that pumped
in sound effects I've enjoyed it much
more because done it's kind of the
familiar noise in your ear so whether
you're making or breakfast or you're
playing with the kids that you put it on
in the background just having that noise
you don't have to watch every second of
the game but just knowing it's there is
a familiarity that we're all craving
just we're all craving familiarity we're
all craving our old life so that for me
sort of fills that hole
I know it's artificial but it didn't
bother me like it didn't bother you so I
think that that could be certainly on
the table watching football with nothing
at all is jarring we would get used to
it and that's okay and and people will
get used to that as well that's
interesting here in the players talk but
I hopefully we haven't finalized our
plans yet down because of course we're
in partnership with Sky Sports so we are
sort of having constant meetings about
it and I'm not yet privy to those but I
would have thought I hope they'll be
making some sort of option what has
happened to Manchester United in the
last five years they didn't plan seven
years they didn't plan so when Sir
Iacocca summer expired they didn't plan
for properly for a successor who could
do what he did and maybe the sport he
left wasn't quite as strong as he made
it look through his own immense
unprecedented talents therefore anyone
coming in is going to struggle as louis
van gaal did as David Moyes did before
him as chosen greenio did as a business
it's spent a lot of money that hasn't
worked out so there's a lot of
disconnect between the fans the board
the football side of things but it is a
is a humungous cruise ship and it is
just beginning to turn around it is just
I feel before lockdown whether you're a
fan of only got a soul show the manager
or not I personally not sure he's the
future but for right now to start the
cruise ships turn he's okay at the wheel
for now she's Rebecca Lowe NBC Sports
Premier League host and of course
hosting the popular digital series
breakfast with
the biggest celebrity in the Premiership
is who also it's a it's a coach or a
manager at Manchester City High I mean I
would say in terms of in terms of kind
of status yes I would probably say Pep
Guardiola is that is the absolute
Hollywood glamour superstar I mean
there's tons of superstars but if you're
talking the elite elite I would say that
body oh but you know you you've got
Kevin de Bruyne er you've got Sergio
agüero they're all massive massive names
down I mean virtually I would say 70% of
the Premier League of massive names but
Pep Guardiola has done it and done it
over and over again and he's done it in
a way that no one's ever done it before
in the style of football that he
produced for his team so right now for
me
I mean it's faded a little bit with the
emergence of the urban crop who I spoke
to this morning actually whose magic so
I hope amazed the two managers I could
take off my body oh yeah you know my
favorite player Harry Kane I love I love
Didier Drogba but I'm I'm more of a you
know now it's Harry King because they
never say can't his name is always Harry
Kane when I whenever he scores Harry
Kane you got okay and he's just cuz
we've talked about he's a prince but
also it's like Tom Brady
it's Harry Kane Tom Brady they're really
good friends did you know that they
aren't they're really friends because
Harry is a huge you know Patriot fan I
think that since one ready baseball not
anymore
I knew that I knew but they went even as
super be FX so yeah and
legend and his evening captain never
losses okay I watched the documentary
series on Sunderland until I died I
thought it was brilliantly done
spectacular just just the passion in
that city and what that that football
team means to that city you know we talk
about life and death
you know we throw that around here in
the United States it felt like it's life
and death for those fans and the
importance and then they kept getting
relegated and you could just see that it
changed their lives it was changing the
city right before your very eyes I don't
think so unless I looked at maybe the
Philadelphia Eagles with their fan base
in what that team means to them I'm sure
I'm Dallas but Dallas and it's a little
bit different I mean Sunderland is this
what shipping city and you know it
they're there it's not a wealthy City at
all they're really reliant on you know
the economy there and their football
team but I I just I came away going and
I hate saying it but I did say it you
don't have to be a soccer fan to love it
because it's really just about
personalities relationships and you know
the hopes and dreams that you have as a
sports fan you just it's all about maybe
this year will be my year maybe this
year will be okay maybe we won't be
rubbish this year and Sunderland's you
said kept falling down the divisions and
they were taken over by different people
and who had that's interesting and all
the way through it the common
denominator is the fans the same people
the taxi driver guy the same people
going to the games no matter who's in
charge and no matter who's playing and
like you say it affects their lives and
that actually that documentary gives you
an insight so why it's so important we
get football back in the UK because
those people and there are millions of
them like those on the lip and they're
lost
they're lost by what's happening anyway
and they're lost by having the huge part
of their life taken away from them so of
course it's a terrible time and we would
never forget that and we must never
forget and that will remain the constant
theme now for a long time but there's
nothing wrong with being happy and
joyful but something that means a huge
amount to you is coming back into your
life I think that's okay it's a tough
balance and we're gonna have to strike
it when I go back on air in a couple of
weeks striking that balance between
poignancy and sadness and what's going
on in the world and joy and excitement
something separate from that and once
again people make this mistake Westham
their their nickname is not the wankers
it's right so Paulie always brings this
up he said you gotta ask Rebecca that
was their old nickname day the workers
you know I say if you continue to use
that work I've told you about that word
it's not even on television in England
until after 10:30 at night even then you
won't even find it it's a remercie rude
and it's just I just stopped already
Paulie
will you stop with that my bad boy stop
saying wanker I had to remind him what
he was saying and he shouldn't be saying
it and I'm sick of that Paulie I bet I
that everything's a joke when it comes
to the Premier League
it's the Liverpool I'm all messed up
yeah paulie's Liverpool squad is gonna
gonna win is there any chance that
Liverpool doesn't win it's great to see
you and I hope Teddy's behaving and we
look forward to the Premier League
returning to NBC Sports on Wednesday
June 17th and of course the popular
digital series sweeping the nation
sweeping the world breakfast with Beck's
it's David Beckham and Rebecca Lowe
drinking Beck's beer it's a whole lot of
fun the way you say that great thank you
Thank You Rebecca that's Rebecca Lowe
NBC Sports primarily